What makes it art capital?
Well,
I think I go back to my spin ball
question at the beginning,
which is artists making interesting work
in an artistic environment that's
conducive for them to make it.
When people talk about London as an art
capital in very positive terms.
The word they always use is the word
they used to only use about New York and
that's energy and there's a sense that
when a,
when a certain dynamic occurs,
an energy that kind of pervasive sense
of energy is produced and this seems to
me to be an absolute critical thing and
the artists were very central to making
that happen.
But,
but that,
that seems to me to be the,
the edge of difference between a place
that's really got something happening
and something someplace that's a nice
showcase or something,
but it doesn't have that inner vitality.
I'd like to say that if there is the
energy that it will translate into
something positive.
Um,
and I've certainly seen examples as I
said in South Asia where there hasn't
been government funding.
Whereas cities have become very,
very interesting spaces for artists.
But on the other hand,
having seen the examples of Hong Kong
and Singapore where the government does
fund various schemes and does fund art
schools and art education and
institutions and everything else that
goes along with it,
it is much easier for artists to live in
that environment and for an art capital
to grow out of that environment.
Yeah,
I think it's a city.
You just have to be able to attract
people who are artists,
which is echoing something you said
earlier and maybe you have to be a bit
of a mess of a city sometimes to do
that.
You have to be interested in in in ways
that might be messy ways.
I mean,
I lived in Los Angeles for a long time
and there was a very odd ball art group
of artists there.
They were really mavericks who didn't
want to go to New York.
I mean,
by choosing to be in Los Angeles,
they were really thumbing their nose at
the artist stablish mint.
But it included people like every Shay,
Mike,
Kelly,
Paul Mccarthy,
Chris Burden,
Raymond Pettibone,
artists who are very well known,
but they were all extremely eccentric,
uh,
and they really didn't want to be part
of this art establishment in La,
especially when I was living.
There was much more of a messy place
just like the way in London in some
ways.
It's kind of a messy labyrinthine city,
uh,
spread out over miles scenerio.
It's,
um,
so I think when I think of a place like
Singapore,
I think it's got to get a little
dirtier.